Okay.
Located between the Pacific Ocean and
the Caribbean Sea.
We could say Columbia is something like
the entry and exit door of South
America.
You know what?
Well this,
this is Columbia,
the long and it's cheerful beaches of
Santa Marta.
The lower he red desert,
the inaccessible the teeth.capital of
the leafy Colombian Amazon rain forest.
Then there are the islands of San Andres
and providence.
Yeah,
the coffee bells of Quinn Dio,
cal drows and raise Eraldo and then
there are of course the vibrant cities
of Midean Kelly or baron Quia,
and we can't forget about the historical
and proud Carter he know or the Frantic
Bogus,
Huh?
Very good.
I'll be in the great capital city of the
country that dear viewers with its
candelaria and it's incredible museums
of Golden Arch.
We'll leave you absolutely speechless.
Yes.
We can't really be surprised that more
and more travel companies are making
Columbia a 100% must visit destination.
Right.
As you might've guessed this video,
it's not going to be about tourism in
Colombia.
Not at all.
It's politics that we do here at visual
politic.
I mean it's right there in the name.
May,
2018 Columbia will have its next
presidential election and by August 7th
whoever wind will have begun his new
job.
Juan Manuel Santos,
the current president cannot run again
as he has reached his two term limit.
Santos is tying is coming to an end with
this video.
We want to take a look ahead and to find
out what kind of Columbia he is going to
leave to his successor.
We're going to have a look at the great
things.
Well,
there's the not so great.
Yeah.
Days.
Columbia,
a gambling man,
a great poker player and part of one of
the most influential families in
Colombia.
This is Juan Manuel Santos.
Even his great uncle at the water though
Santos was President of Columbia in the
late thirties his family also owned a
temple,
the most influential newspaper in the
country.
It's the very same.
Juan Manuel Santos was for a long time.
Deputy director ans a colonist apps,
the newspaper.
What do we are trying to say is that
this family,
they've never lacked influence money or
power.
Sorry,
off to two times the 7th of August,
2017 marks the end of his time as
president.
And to be honest,
his level of popularity,
it's pretty much shot rock in Boston.
This is even after winning the Nobel
Peace Prize due to the deal that he got
with FARC.
The latest poll numbers when we're
making this video showed that 65 to 75%
of Columbian people disapprove of his
governance.
So the question now is,
how does the Nobel prize winning leader
have such strong disapproval ratings
from his own?
Perhaps it has to do with this broken
promise about
the peace deal with foc.
Remember,
he assured them that it was going to be
the Colombian people and no one else.
You were going to have the last word on
the deal and well,
let's just say that Santos forgot all
about that.
Columbia referendum voters reject peace,
deal with bark,
gorillas,
Colombia,
the FARC sign,
new peace deal.
This time skipping voters
bosses.
Apart from all of this.
If there is really something that can
make an assumption low ratings,
well,
while I won't have to be via economy.
Yep.
During the last decade,
this Pacific Kuma called Columbia,
well,
you know,
it used to have quite strong grief and
it even became one of the most thriving
of the Latin American countries.
However,
lately things have been emailed a little
bit difference that actually they've
been really quite a lot different.
I mean,
have a look at this chart.
Columbia is facing a situation of slow
down,
which is really much closer to what we'd
call stagnation.
The latest growth figures show a year on
year increase of slightly above 1% and
2017 forecasts don't seem to be that
much better at all
be as economic growth rate will be 1.5%
in 2017 according to bb va research.
As you can see,
this is really not a good figure,
especially if we consider that most of
the richest countries are growing at
higher rates.
The United States,
Canada,
Spain,
Germany,
UK,
all of them will grow more than Columbia
in 2017 as well.
It's kind of supposed to be that when
you're a poorer country you grow more.
This is because of something that is
called economic convergence.
So well now the question has to become
what's going on in Colombia and he
blamed the situation on the fall of oil
and commodity prices and you know in a
way this is sort of rice,
but there are some nuances that we do
need to consider.
Now,
it is true that it,
its climax in 2013 oil did represent
more than 50% of all the country's
exports.
More than 30% of all foreign direct
investments has more than 20% of public
reserve.
But it's
also true that for many years,
thanks to the high oil prices,
the governance of Columbia has had more
resources than it's ever happened
before.
Resources that could have been used to
boost a productive and competitive
economy unrelated to those original
commodities.
And this is something if at the Santos
Administration seems to not really have
done,
perhaps this is because they've been
dedicated.
This is almost exclusively to that peace
deal with fuck.
Anyway,
let's now have a look at what are the
main weaknesses of the Colombian
economy?
Disastrous infrastructure.
For years Columbia's been,
I'll should we say it's almost a failed
state in many areas.
These are areas that were controlled by
warlords,
gorillas and militias and narchos.
All of those things,
so now imagine how difficult it would be
to manage such a country ans build
complex infrastructure there.
But really the reality is that that's
not the whole school,
Laurie.
The reality is that infrastructure has
never been a major priority for any
Colombian government and the results of
this,
it's pretty obvious.
The infrastructure in Colombia,
it's really,
really bad today to describe Columbia is
infrastructure that we can use.
Really any other word,
the dreadful,
most of their paved roads,
they're in a state of total disrepair as
well.
Was the result of all of this and do you
pay close attention to this?
Because while there's almost
unbelievable
football
container within the country is twice as
expensive as in Mexico or Bolivia and
four times more expensive than in
Argentina Gla or,
and in fact the situation is so
disastrous that free transport between
the Colombian ports of,
of interior around Bogota is three times
more expensive than moving the same load
from a rotterdam,
Frank Franklin.
Interestingly,
there are some reports that claimed that
sending a container from Carta Haina is
a blue guitar costs three times more
than sending it to Shanghai.
Hi,
so now you can probably imagine all of
the effects that this has on supply
costs,
prices and the competitiveness of
Colombian companies.
According to a recent OACD report,
Columbia is the third world's most
expensive country from which to export
containers after Venezuela and Russia.
That's why Hahnemann well sent us
decided in 2010 to make changing.
This is top priority and it is true.
That is government has just released the
biggest infrastructure plan in the
history of Columbia.
A private co-funded plan,
which under a concessionary system is
actually pretty attractive.
Bye.
[inaudible] must which three study?
Yes.
This plan,
it actually seems to be well designed
bars after seven years.
It's just a bit too late and it still
comes with many problems.
Is that the honest during his two terms,
Santos achievements are really haven't
been as good as he promised that they
were going to be.
Your rocker C and taxes
both the World Economic Forum,
I'm the world's bank,
confirmed the Columbia is one of the
countries with the highest taxes on
companies in the wells,
which is obviously something that
doesn't help companies to grow and
develop according to the paying taxes
reports that every year price waterhouse
coopers publishers,
the total of all taxes,
the declan via and the company has to
pay is 69.8% of their pre tax port.
That's almost 70% which is significantly
higher than in countries like Germany,
Spain,
the United States.
To be honest,
it's pretty insane.
I think that's not even mentioning the
bureaucracy,
which has an almost equal level of pure
insanity.
Once they were really gonna have to make
a video about the passion for
bureaucracy.
The last in America seems to have a book
because it would be really long.
We're not going to touch on it in
today's video.
It's just too huge of a topic.
But what we can say is that on an
average day in Columbia,
15 rules and three decrees are issued.
Okay?
Yes,
really every single day,
not just that,
but according to research conducted by
the University of last banner,
more than 30% of the laws passed are
useless.
Tans just create costs for Colombian
society.
And so what is quantum mainwell Santos
has done to solve all of these issues?
Well,
he's done almost nothing.
In fact,
he has made the situation even worse.
Persistence,
violence.
It is true that many aspects where they
to do security are improving in
Colombia.
The uptick in the tourism industry in
the country is pretty good evidence of
bass.
In 2016 fundings,
million tourists visited the country,
which is twice the number from 2010 and
almost 10 times the number from 2000
which is certainly not bad.
However,
despite this in many areas of the
country,
the situation,
it's not really improving.
Okay.
Cording to the United Nations and the
Colombian conflict analysis resource
center,
there is still violence in the most
affected areas of the country.
That is the FARC peace deal has not
substantially improved the situation in
these areas.
For example,
kept on growing and cocaine refining is
at its absolute highest.
Me Just have a look at this chart,
so well now you might be wondering how
is it possible that violence levels and
the production of illicit substances has
not been reduced since the governments
deal with fuck?
Well that's because responding to all
the marketing from the government's
Indwell,
the violence by FARC was huge.
It actually represents it less than 10%
of the nation's total violence and more
over the areas that FARC have left have
not been occupied by government
institutions but by other Naco ends,
militia groups,
some of them even having a mutual
agreement with fog after all the
business,
it's still very attractive.
Now the peace deal left and many things
up in the APP and that's why these so
called peace dividends is not giving
results as big as the government
promised.
Now to be fair though,
not everything has been totally bad
under Santos,
his presidency,
the best of the centers administration,
we have to admit that Juan Manuel Santos
has achieved some pretty good things is
government actually brought Columbia to
the Pacific alliance and this is another
thing going to talk about in an upcoming
video,
so do not forget to subscribe,
hit that button below.
Of course it's foreign agenda.
It has been a great strength of his
government.
Columbia today is more open to the world
than it ever has been before,
so that poverty has been reduced
considerably and the country has
attracted lots of foreign investment.
Bye.
Despite all of this,
our impression here at visual politic
isn't the arrival of a new government
can really be a positive turning point
for Columbia.
When one manual Santos took office,
the country seemed to be ready to tackle
a real process of transformation and
their oil resources meds that they have
the ability to pay for us.
However,
this as of yes,
it simply hasn't been achieved.
In fact,
it's kind of been the opposite.
Santos leaves a weak economic Columbia
and many more future prospects than
current realities.
So now we'd love to know your opinion.
What do you think the future of Columbia
will be?
How would you rate Santos as a
president?
Well,
you can leave your opinion in the
comments below and also in this quick
survey,
and if you enjoy this video,
you can let us know by hitting that like
button.
Also,
do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
the one on mine,
and as always,
thank you for awhile.
Yeah.